[Musik]
Leute ich habe mich doch oh scheiße
geiles Hochzeitsoutfit es ist was
passiert ich weiß ja nicht ob ihr es
schon gesehen habt wenn ihr nur meine
Adventskalender Videos schaut
wahrscheinlich habt ihr es dann noch
nicht mitbekommen ja aber meine anderen
Videos auch mal zwischendurch schauen
der hat
das hier mitbekommen
[Musik]
auch wenn wir Leute gratulieren und
sagen ah nein kann nicht normal
reagieren ich kann nicht sagen oh ja
vielen Dank ja wir freuen uns auch hier
bei mir ist immer so
es war auch langsam Zeit will nicht
ehrlich mit euch es war Zeit ich ich ich
ich sehe einfach aus wie eine Frau das
Ding ist ein Schlafanzug von Hunkemöller
und das hier habe ich zu meiner
Kommunion in der achten Klasse das hat
meine Mutter glaube ich damals selber
gemacht katholische Kirche ist irgendwie
ne also wir müssen nicht damit anfangen
dass sie weird ist warum sah ich bei
meiner Kommunion aus wie so eine kleine
Braut irgendwie aber so sahen alle aus
das ist ein richtiges Kleid an so ein
Schleier naja speaking of trauma unser
Adventskalender Traummann geht wieder
los ich weiß beruhigt euch nimmt euch
eine Tüte
einmal tief durchatmen für die nächsten
zwei Monate gilt auf diesem Kanal nur
ein Motto Auspacken Auspacken
auspacken und ich habe wirklich viele
Gedanken gemacht welcher der erste
Adventskalender sein sollte und dazu
muss man noch beachten das ist noch
nicht viele gibt die geliefert werden
versucht die ganze Zeit nebenbei so die
Firmen an zu betteln so gibt mir den
doch schon mal vorher ich weiß der wird
erst im November geliefert aber kommt
äh und als ob es das Schicksal möchte
gab es ein Kalender der sehr schnell
geliefert wurde der Braut
Adventskalender aufmerksame Augen haben
schon erkannt es gibt hier nur fünf
Türchen warum nur fünf Türchen erster
Advent Dritter Advent und Weihnachten
macht es nicht viel mehr Sinn dass ein
Adventskalender 5 Türchen hat für den
Advent für jeden Advent das ist sogar
eine viel bessere Idee wenn man zum
Beispiel jemanden einen Adventskalender
basteln möchte und ein bisschen
hochwertigere Sachen reinmachen will
dann macht man einfach nur für die
Advents Tage einen Adventskalender
kleiner Tipp hier für euch Geld sparen
das ist das Motto nicht auf diesem Kanal
die nächsten Wochen der
hochzeitscountdown Kalender dieser
Kalender kostet stolze 69,95 € 14 € pro
Türchen wir sind gespannt ich muss auch
langsam mal in diese Hochzeitsbranche
reingehen ich glaube da wird so viel
Geld mit verdient mit Hochzeiten wir
haben auch schon so ein bisschen geguckt
wie denn unsere Hochzeit so womöglich
sein könnte und es ist einfach alles so
geisteskrank teuer doch bevor ich das
erste Türchen öffne muss ich euch eine
Sache sagen dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses Videos
nicht gesponsert ist wirklich sehr klein
ne der ist wirklich sehr klein wenn man
mal überlegt was für große Kalender ich
teilweise habt das ist wirklich so ein
kleines ist keine süß erstmal zum
optischen sehr schön sehr schlecht kann
man nichts falsch machen ist cute
gefällt uns die Größe ist wirklich
verrückt ne also es ist sehr klein sonst
hat man ja so sehr große Kalender aber
gut dass wenn man bei fünf Türchen haben
ne das ist der erste Advent wir gehen zu
unserem
Adventskalender und ähm schauen mal was
ich so denn als Braut brauche dieser
Kalender passt wirklich super gerade ich
bin sehr gespannt oh ich sehe schon eine
Sache
ist drin
mit dem Heiraten durchziehen möchte
Sprite ist Liebing na klar darf ich das
eigentlich dann ab jetzt schon tragen
bin ich ab jetzt schon die Braut oder
darf ich das dann wirklich erst am Braut
Wochenende tragen gibt's dafür eine
Regel
es riecht ganz gut ich glaube das Lager
von der Person wo das so alles verpackt
wird riecht auch gut ist eine nette
Sache ne 14 €, also wenn ich was
Schlafmasken Kosten Türchen du magst
zwei ich habe auch ein bisschen das
Gefühl das steckt so richtig in meiner
DNA ich brauche gar nicht darüber
nachdenken was ich sage oder wie ich das
tue das ist einfach drin seit 2017 packe
ich Adventskalender aus 70 seit 2017
packe ich Adventskalender aus könnt ihr
euch das vorstellen das ist sechs Jahre
in Tütchen Nummer zwei befindet sich oh
je eine kleine Schachtel mit Happy
bright drauf und drin befindet sich eine
Kette
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich diese Kette
am Altar tragen würde aber wer weiß
vielleicht seht ihr mich irgendwann mal
mit dieser Kette ist nicht so eine gute
Qualität ist
925 Silber ist doch Gold dabei handelt
es sich um eine Legierung aus
92,5 % reinem Silber und 7,5 andere
Metallen in der Regel Kupfer ich finde
diese Perle da vorne sieht einfach sehr
billig aus sieht auch nicht so einen
schönen Glanz die hat er so ein
Plastiklook aber es ist schön
das hat noch gefehlt ja gut das ist auf
jeden Fall am ja ich meine ich brauche
es als Braut bestimmt aber ich würde ja
wenn ich heirate vielleicht mir selber
eine Kette aussuchen wollen die perfekt
zu den Ohrringen passt die ich trage
oder zum Kleid oder whatever wisst ihr
was ich meine frag mich gerade also ja
es passt für eine Braut aber was ist
denn ich es ist der dritte Advent ui ui
ui wir haben schon ein bisschen Glühwein
drin und wir freuen uns auf die Hochzeit
die man selber planen muss und das super
anstrengend und teuer wird aber dann
machen wir unser Kalendertürchen auf und
wir
was haben wir hier oh es riecht sehr gut
ein Sack mit Nein äh Badebomben ich
glaube das sind ja das sind
blabladebomben es ist schon süßes
Tierchen so Seife nee sind Badebomben
aber es sind ganz schön kleine
Badebomben es riecht aber sehr gut
wollte mal riechen
ich denke gerade an 70 €
mal aus ich meine der muss ja eigentlich
muss er mir ja wirklich jetzt gefallen
weil ich bin ja die Braut weiter geht's
mit Türchen Nummer 4 4 Advent weil das
Weihnachten hey Leute bald ist wirklich
schon Weihnachten
passenden Ohrringe
ich meine ausziehen oh die sind so
hübsch
aber den mein Problem gerade versteht
hier ist boah Alter meine Fingernägel
das geht gar nicht es tut mir so leid
ich habe an alles gedacht aber nicht an
meine Fingernägel
nicht dieses Gummi Ding lässt sich nicht
ablösen ich mache nicht mal ein Scherz
ich dachte am Anfang so äh es geht nicht
ab
oh jetzt gings da Klebstoff dran oder
was erstmal ins Ohr stecken
ey ich will wollte noch ein bisschen
nett sein aber der ist hier so verbogen
aber die sind die Kombination ist
eigentlich ganz hübsch ne willst du
vielleicht nicht an meiner Hochzeit
tragen würde dann eher so Polterabend
und Frühstück am nächsten Tag so
ungefähr da würde ich vielleicht tragen
okay jetzt Christmas Day uh
it's Christmas ich liebe Weihnachten und
ich liebe dass ich heiraten werde und
jetzt habe ich einen
heirats-adventskalender Hochzeit
Adventskalender und ich mache die 24
auch und drin ist ganz kurz nach diesem
Beutel total
das ist also es ist halt ja es ist so
ein ich will gar nicht sagen bei der
Klamotte aber das ist so ein einmal
gebraucht das ist so oh ich bin dann
einmal Braut und dann machen wir cute
Fotos mit den Brautjungfern und ich habe
das dann auch an und ich meine
vielleicht kann ich das noch als
Morgenmantel anziehen aber warum sollte
mein Leben lang und Morgenmantel
anziehen okay aber es ist so ein
typisches braut-artikel Ding ein get it
ja die Qualität ist okay
das Schild hier wieso oh Größe L das ist
ein gutes Mittelding da passen die
meisten Leute rein made in chihan und
wart ihr schon mal in chihan wie kann
man für so ein Schild made in China
schreiben
ist wirklich das Model
also falls ihr noch nicht gemerkt habt
ich bin heute hier die Braut ja ich weiß
nicht was ich erwartet habe ich weiß es
wirklich nicht ich meine es übertrifft
meine Erwartungen vielleicht bin ich
auch einfach nicht wie die anderen und
diese bra sind einfach nichts für mich
ich bin ganz an ich bin ganz anders okay
was haben wir hier die Kette die
Ohrringe das das ehrlich gesagt bin ich
jetzt gerade noch verwirrter als vorher
das ist doch nicht erlaubt du kannst
doch nicht etwas verkaufen wo du nicht
die Inhaltsstoffe mit reinpackst also
klar was soll so eine Badebombe schon
bewirken aber manche Leute haben ja
wirklich schlimme Allergien
und da kann also würde man doch gerne
wissen wollen okay was ist hier drin
gerade wenn Du ja jemanden diesen
Kalender schenkst Kalender werden ja oft
verschenken wenn ich das jetzt sagt hey
Vanessa aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich
auf der Webseite dann beschrieben was da
so drin ist da müsste wenigstens
Schildchen mit dabei gewesen sein war es
aber nicht weil das halt so
selbstgemacht ist und deswegen vermute
ich auch das dahinter eine ganz nette
Person steckt wie das sich so überlegt
hat und wo die Kalkulation am Ende mit
den 70 € bestimmt auch total hinhaut
wenn man ihre Arbeitszeit bedenkt dass
sie diese Verpackung ja auch herstellen
muss und was nicht alles da noch hinter
steckt ich habe aber das Gefühl dass
dieser Adventskalender mag so heiß
umstritten ist und kämpft umstritten
kann er auch sein der ist heiß umkämpft
jede Marke hat mittlerweile ein
Adventskalender und wenn du dich dazu
entscheidest dir selber einzukaufen oder
eine anderen Person Einkaufen zu wollen
dann weiß ich nicht ob jeder ist auch
versuchen sollte ein Kalender
herzustellen das ist glaube ich das was
ich zu sagen habe es ist wirklich eine
nette Sache und ich bin vielleicht auch
einfach nicht die richtige Braut dafür
ich finde es ja auch super gut ja es ist
ja okay doch der ist okay ich finde der
Kalender hat seine Pluspunkte und ich
finde das sind auch eigentlich süße
Artikel mit dem Schmuck naja ich muss
noch ein bisschen gucken also eigentlich
hat sieht er ganz hübsch aus und passt
aber ich würde jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht den Schmuck zu meiner Hochzeit
anziehen ich will nicht sagen dass ich
den Kalender super finde und ich finde
dass meine 70 € super investiert sind
ich will aber auch nicht sagen dass er
absolut Trash ist ich schwimme wieso
dazwischen und ich glaube es gibt heute
die das hier auspacken und es ist super
cute finden und sowas noch nicht haben
und z.B ich habe genau die gleiche
Schlafmaske deswegen ist es schon ein
bisschen und für die dieser Kalender
ganz toll ist aber wiederum 70 €, ne
hallo jetzt habt ihr alles bekommen
Vanessa im Hochzeitskleid ein kleiner
Adventskalender rennt ich möchte aber
eigentlich auch noch mal in diese Person
die diesen Kalender erstellt hat das ist
wirklich eine super Idee ich weiß aber
nicht ob 70 €, ob das nicht ein bisschen
viel ist Wasser geh zu dem
Adventskalender wie geht es Euch gerade
was macht ihr so schreibt mir gerne in
die Kommentare vergesst nicht einen
Daumen nach oben zu geben wenn ihr euch
auch auf adventskalendert und wir sehen
uns dann das nächste mal wieder was
schon sehr bald sein wird also ne bis
gleich würde ich eher sagen will
irgendwie noch nicht die Kamera
ausmachen wenn ich die Kamera raus mache
bedeutet das dass ich den Schleier
ausziehen muss mich dann nicht mehr wie
eine hübsche Braut fühlen kann